éclipse tous doivent et tous les pays
avec les pays arabes malgré le potentiel
de conflits au sein du monde arabe et
avec israël et nous allons partir de la
nécessité d'avoir de bonnes relations
justement avec l'ensemble de ces pays
pour chercher à comprendre leurs
problèmes leurs besoins et les prendre
en compte dans notre approche
pas seulement avec ces pays mais aussi
avec les pays pour lesquels ce
partenariat pose un problème et j'ai
cette question qui avait été posée
est-ce que la russie va manquer un
portail avec les états unis la chine sur
ce plan non nous n'allons pas manquer
une telle occasion si nous avons la
possibilité de de travailler ensemble
cela il ya un développement historique
il ya un potentiel historique à utiliser
à faire valoir dans cette région que ce
soit d'autres régions aussi s'il y a des
efforts en commun qui peuvent être faits
nous sommes prêts à y participer
nous n'allons rien imposé à personne
l'intérêt ici c'est que ce qui est
d'éviter des crises millier de
militaires mais mais aussi d'abord et
avant tout à résoudre cette vieille
écluse en ce qui concerne l'afrique
il faut que ce soit une zone de
stabilité nous avons pas d'intérêts
stratégiques à soutenir un chaos
organisé
je sais que certains pays hors de la
région où un intérêt à un tel chaos
donc nous n'avons pas d'intérêt ici à
des confrontations frontale entre
différents pays à l'utilisation de
prétextes dans différentes dans
différentes situations nous sommes aux
comptes et un suppôt des relations
économiques commerciales
institutionnelles normale entre ses plis
et nous ne voulons pas que tel ou tel
pays dans cette zone répète le sort que
connaît la libye
participeront activement aux efforts de
mise en place le respect du droit
international
c'est pas pour qu'il n'y ait pas de de
mensonges sur les âmes les armes de
destruction massive dans des pays de la
région comme c'est fait par exemple pour
la syrie ou pour la libye comme je l'aï
dit à propos d' armes chimiques
prétendument trouver encore une fois ici
ce sont des secrets de polichinelle
quand on voit ces formulations qui sont
utilisés mais ce que nous voulons c'est
il un avantage de ces des relations
excepté un avantage qui est économique
mais avant tout nous avons beaucoup de
choses en commun sur le plan d'eau sur
le plan du droit international de
dialogue international du respect de la
charte de l'onu avec la population pour
la population musulmane de la fédération
de russie c'est important d'avoir des
bonnes relations avec les autres pays du
golfe avec les pays du monde arabe
et tout cela nous voulons évidemment le
soutenir et développer
nous n'allons pas chercher à trouver un
intérêt dans la prolongation du chaos au
contraire nouveau la stabilisation et
que
la percée la fédération aussi soit perçu
comme un partenaire fiable et stable
ce que nous voulons c'est que nous ayons
ici des relations normales merci
beaucoup
bonjour sogué victorovitch merci de
cette opportunité j'ai une question liée
à des événements récents les changements
que nous avons eu récemment constitution
qui est entré en force avec des
amendements et maintenant ça contient
une norme selon laquelle la délimitation
la démarcation des frontières d'état de
la fédération de russie avec des pays
voisins
s'il y a des
choses comme ça qui se passe donc les
appels à se faire sont inaccessibles
pour a quand il s'agit de prendre des
territoires de la fédération de russie
donc une forme la norme c'est clair et
dans ce contexte je voudrais poser les
questions sur un an négociations avec le
japon sur la question territoriale est
ce que ces négociations aujourd'hui sont
anticonstitutionnelles ce que pour les
îles des kouriles
il ne suffit pas de temps vous vous
trompez pas mais nos relations avec le
japon s'appuie sur un certain nombre
d'accords et la fédération de russie
comme pays
héritier de l'union sovétique se dit
attaché à respecter les accords conclus
par l'union soviétique le président
poutine a rappelé à plusieurs reprises
cela concerne aussi la déclaration de
1956 selon laquelle nous sommes d'accord
et nous discutons avec nos collègues
japonais de
conclure un accord de paix de près et
c'est pas seulement la fin de l'état de
guerre certains au chapon souhaiterait
mais l'état de guerre entre la russie à
l'époque le nous ce métier qu'est le
japon par cette déclaration de 1956 où
les techniques et il n'ya plus de guerre
et que nous établissons des relations
diplomatiques
voilà le traité de paix
dont il est question c'est un traité
contemporain actualisé qui doit
correspondre aux nécessités qui sont
différentes de celles différente de
celle d'il ya soixante ans pour mettre
en place des relations complètes
donc ce document doit être globale sur
le bon voisinage le partenariat l'amitié
et concerner l'ensemble de nos relations
qu'il s'agisse de l'économie il ya des
proches des progrès mais pas dans tous
les domaines n'oublions pas que des
sanctions reste de la part de nos
voisins japonais s'est elle sont pas
aussi marqué que du côté américain
enfin elle existe il y a des aspects sur
la sécurité qui doivent être stipulé
compte tenu du fait que les américains
entretiennent des relations de
partenariat militaire extrêmement
étroite avec le japon donc il faudrait
un traité de paix complet globale qui
permette d'envisager complètement jeunot
nos relations diplomatiques qui
divergent sur beaucoup de points donc il
ya beaucoup d'aspects aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons proposé une
formulation d'un tel traité de paix mais
pour l'instant nos collègues japonais ne
répond spa ne fondent pas précisément à
notre proposition et tout cela doit
permettre de déterminer l'évolution et
l'avenir de nos relations avec le japon
mais les délais
les officiels japonais ont souvent
déclaré qu'il ne reconnaissait pas les
résultats de la deuxième guerre mondiale
qu'il reconnaissait sauf sur le plan de
la des îles kouriles du sud
je mets ça se battre est ce que le japon
à signer la charte de l'onu et qui il y
à l'article 107 qui dit que les
résultats de la des guerres ne doivent
pas être contestées j'écoute les
déclarations de nos collègues japonais
et qui disent que dégagement un traité
de paix sera signée devez que la
question territoriale soient réglés or
c'est pas à ça que nous nous sommes
prêtes il ya près encore une fois merci
beaucoup saké victorovitch nous avons eu
une très bonne réunion sur land avec les
participations de la basse at her indien
et du hamas et de russes en délit hier
j'ai reçu une lettre de remerciement
dans lequel massador a évoqué qu'il
avait pris plaisir à cette discussion
sur maintenant je donne la parole à
l'excellent jan ove qui avait participé
à cette discussion
merci beaucoup la russie est critique
souvent les états unis pour promouvoir
dans la région pacifique des structures
non inclusif qui vise à isoler
les pays qu'ils sont cons fortes
ambitions on peut dire pour les états
unis je parle du et ce genre de phares
noirs men nous mène dans la
confrontation
ce n'est pas ce qui correspond à nos
intérêts pourtant on voit que le milieu
l'inde et d'autres partenaires
stratégiques soutiennent ce format quad
et propose d'inviter notre partenaire
stratégique on voit donc il ya cette
nécessité de renforcer la sécurité dans
la région la russie pourrait-elle offrir
près proposer une alternative à ce
format pour ne pas créer une situation
compliquée oui j'ai déjà abordé ce sujet
la manifestation il ya quelques années
dans la conception de indo pacifique est
une stratégie élaboré par les diplomates
américains de la région
indo pacifique dit ouverte et vous savez
comme une institution institutions de ce
type se déclare ouverte
vous savez ça suscite plutôt
l'impression que c'est
c'est plutôt de la publicité parce que
si on n'invite pas des voisins je vois
pas tellement comment ses couverts donc
cette stratégie signifie tels que
maintenant il s'agit pas de la région
indo pacifique avec les différentes
organisations internationales qui ont
été mises en place autour de la zone
avec le forum de sécurité la conférence
des ministres de la défense de lausanne
qui est un mécanisme très important il y
a les différents sommets d'asie du
sud-est qui fêtent leurs 10 ans cette
année et auquel la russie avec les
venues d'ailleurs cessé juin donc tout
cela il ya des mécanismes ouvert
inclusif qui ont été mises en place que
chacun est invité
et comme nous avons posé la question de
savoir pourquoi cet espace indo
pacifique était plus éloignée plus
élargie et maintenant tous les pays
proches
pour être invités on nous a dit non
alors à ce moment là pourquoi pourquoi
le golfe persique qui fait partie de
l'océan indien peut-être un été on nous
a dit non non il ya trop de problème
donc golfe persique donc on peut pas
l'inclure dans cette initiative
et si vous regardez les idées qui ont
été formulées dans ce quart tête je
laisse daddy mais on ne cache pas que
c'est lié à des tentatives de retenir de
maintenir la la chine est donc ce
partenariat avec l'indh et quelque chose
très claire et l'inde en promouvant sa
politique multi sectoriels et multi
polaire cherche justement tu as intérêt
trouve son intérêt à travailler avec
d'autres pays tels que le japon et
d'autres pays de la région mais elle ne
veut pas que le prix de cette avance de
l' avantage de cette coopération soit
une difficulté supplémentaire avec la
chine il ya eu encore récemment des
incidents regrettables
sur la ligne de contact mais je vois
qu'il ya eu immédiatement des groupes de
contacts qui se sont mises en place
donc il ya des discussions ils ont la
désescalade qui se sont lancés et tout
cela c'est important nous voyons un
intérêt de la part des chinois comme des
indiens veulent éviter une aggravation
de la situation
donc encore une fois avant de discuter
sérieusement de ce partenariat
indo pacifique il faut répondre à la
question de savoir pourquoi
7 cette terminologie est l employé il y
à l'inde dans la mesure où c'est l'océan
dire mais mais il ya aussi des choses si
je suis encore parlé du système étendu
des instruments politiques autour de
l'asian l'asian c'est un ensemble de
pays qui par leur dimension culturelle
ou des approches en commun qui
recherchent le consensus l'equilibre des
intérêts et est depuis des décennies
tout le système des relations sur cette
plateforme de l'asian fonctionnait très
bien
il y avait ces différents forums de
coopération de sécurité etc
et il ya même une expression il ya assez
one way qui souligne que c'est un mode
de discussion qui fonctionne éviter de
chercher la confrontation éviter de
mettre en place des projets qui vont
susciter des problèmes etc
or malheureusement cette stratégie indo
pacifique mis en place par les
américains cherchent d'autres objectifs
poursuit d'autres objectifs et qui
correspondent aux griefs qui sont
formulées par les américains l'encontre
de la chine de façon assez sévères ils
veulent utiliser ce mécanisme pour
renforcer la pression sur la chaîne nous
nous voyons là rien de positif
les problèmes doivent être résolus par
la paix par la discussion et en
utilisant la plateforme de la seranne
qui a été mise en place et qui convient
parfaitement
pour l'ensemble des participants de tous
les problèmes ont été discutés lassant
rhétorique sans polémique
ils sont renforcer les pressions et nous
je lui ai déjà dit plusieurs fois nous
avons avec la séan avec le triste et
shanghai avec l'union économique
eurasiatique
nous avons informé formal discussions et
nous allons continuer à encourager le
format de la série
et si la stratégie indo pacifique
devient plus claire plus évidente et si
nous voyons que ils agissent pour s'unir
aux efforts de des processus de l'asean
et non pas de les zapper et pour établir
un dialogue dans cette religion sans
exclure la chine ou tout autre pays à ce
moment là oui nous nous les salons mais
pour l'instant nous ne le voyons pas
merci 5 électrique les questions des
chercheurs sont épuisés et nous passons
aux questions des médias
votre micro est trop sensible donc je
vous demande si c'est pour ne pas trop
penché sur votre sac et prix love
je vous donne la parole merci bonjour je
voudrais remercier mes mots interfax de
m'avoir invité en tant que représentant
de la télévision et chef l'association
énergétique
je dois dire que nous avons terminé avec
succès notre cycle rsa
nous avons eu plus large y semant la
liste je ne participe pas ils nous
préparent en rapport les dix nouvelles
idées pour les 10 années suivantes dans
l'énergie ma question sera plutôt demain
de journalisme il ya une semaine il ya
eu un sondage pour les experts dans
notre et mercier y compris dans le
quinze qui est présenté ci après
l'accusation par les américains des
salles d'anchin russe d'avoir acheté des
talibans pour tuer les militaires
américains en finissant tout les
chercheurs partage l'edhec autres
savaient que monsieur k bulldogs
à noter que l'un des groupes qui existe
aux états unis c'est un groupe qui est
contre le retrait des forces américaines
fin parce qu il est membre des services
spéciaux sont participe activement au
trafic de il je voudrais vous poser la
question sur cette situation que pensez
vous de tout ce chaos
nous avons déjà réagi à tout ce bruit
suscité par les états unis autour de la
spéculation sur les liens entre les
liens entre la russie et les talibans
que nous aurions prétendument inciter à
lutter contre les médias américains
deux heureux que nous aurions même
appelé commettre des attentats mais
encore une fois cela s'appuie sur des
spéculations tout à fait un malhonnête
il n'y a aucun fait qui n'a été proposée
et les ministères le secrétaire d'état à
la défense ne font que des suppositions
tout cela n'est comme suscité
spécialement pour des intérêts
politiques internes à la veille des
élections aux états unis encore une fois
l'administration américaine
ce discret dit elle même elle se couvre
de honte je répète encore une fois c'est
nous c'est des cas dans les années 80
des cas concrets dans les années 80 où
l'administration américaine ou ne
cachait pas livrer des singer et autres
armements au aux moudjahidine du peuple
et que qui tirait sur des soldats
soviétiques je le répète encore une fois
nous sommes intéressés à ce que en
afghanistan la russie comme les états
unis tirent les leçons de l'expérience
connu dans ce pays ou dans l'autre qui a
tant souffert et que la situation
s'apaise
en accord avec les pays voisins qui
s'appelle qu'il s'agisse du pakistan et
que la chine et les autres pays puissent
aider à retrouver la paix en ce qui
concerne les états unis dans le cadre de
ce processus politique nous soutenons
l'accord qui avait été conclu visant au
dialogue avec les talibans et nous par
nos canons de nous apportons notre
soutien à cela il ya des mécanismes de
consultation entre la russie les états
unis la chine qui inclut l'iran le
pakistan
bon pour l'instant cette invitation
faites à l'iran n'a pas été honoré mais
en tout cas ça c'est en raison de ce que
les américains ont fait précédemment
dans le monde met donc au contraire nous
aidons la coopération nous faisons en
sorte de la souvenirs et là c'est par
ces canaux ne pouvons faire passer des
signaux à tel ou tel pays en faveur de
ce thème donc il ya ce format zee de
moscou ne qui regroupe les acteurs de ce
conflit avec des représentants de tous
les voisins sans exclusion et qui
fonctionne bien à propos de ce qui a été
dit sur la drogue en afghanistan et je
commerce que peuvent faire des
militaires américains sur place nous
avons régulièrement des messages qui
notamment aussi par la presse selon
lesquelles en afghanistan est organisée
une contrebande de d'opiacés en
direction d'autres pays notamment de
l'union européenne avec utilisation en
tout cas c'est ce que par l'aviation
militaire d'été de l'otan et des
gouverneurs afghans
annoncée le transport de par des
hélicoptères dépourvu de marque
d'identification dans ces zones est ce
que sous différentes formes
cette contrebande de pia c est mise en
place
pouvons pas aujourd'hui vérifier à 100%
cette information mais enfin ceci dit ce
type d'information vient trop souvent
pour que nous puissions l'ignorer et si
effectivement l'aviation militaire est
utilisé en afghanistan et ça peut être
qu'une l'aviation militaire de l'otan
sur place
donc ça peut être que les services
spéciaux et donc il s'agit ici de voir
clair dans cette situation il faut que
les etats unis eux mêmes ils sont des
organes compétents et qu'ils peuvent qui
selon les termes de la loi peuvent mener
des enquêtes sur ce type de faits au
niveau du contingent américain prévand
présents en afghanistan
si on s'intéresse simplement a défait
fixe on voit que en vingt ans de
présence les américains et d'autres
participants de la coalition en
afghanistan
le flux de narcotiques en provenance de
l'afghanistan vers d'autres pays
en union européenne dans les pays
voisins de la russie et en russie aussi
ce trafic a été multiplié et ni les
américains ni les pays de l'otan sur
place nous mènent une lutte active
contre 7 contre ce trafic de narcotiques
et le représentant de l'onu mme ce souk
a encore dit récemment que les cultures
de pavot voisine directement les bases
américaines
donc encore une fois cela me paraît pas
très correct du point de vue des
etats-unis
si on parle de lutte contre la drogue et
nous avons attiré plusieurs fois
l'occasion d'évoquer ce sujet au conseil
de sécurité de l'onu nous avons lorsque
nous avons écouté des rapports sur
l'afghanistan nous avons appelé nos
partenaires à lutter contre cette
industrie des narcotiques
on nous a répondu que cela ne faisait
pas partie de la mission de l'otan
puisque cette mission est de lutter
contre le reste or on sait très bien que
le narcotrafic est une source de
financement direct pour les terroristes
tout cela est bien connu donc tirer les
conclusions rouler mais encore une fois
nous traitons ce problème avec le plus
grand sérieux
merci ce qu'est vectorielle il nous
reste trois questions des journalistes
je vais vous poser si on permettait
premier vice-président du directeur
général jacky victorovitch quelques
heures après la fin de cette session à
new york se tiendra la session urgente
que l'assemblée générale de re de génie
sur la lutte contre la pandémie allait
sur l'initiative de kir sera
représentant de la russie comment
évaluez vous cette session et à votre
avis cette réaction n'est-elle pas trop
tardive pour le nu et comment
évaluez-vous son rôle le rôle et la
place de ce mouvement
bien sûr nous savons très bien que cette
initiative a été
est dirigée cette année par
l'afghanistan et donc soumettre à
l'assemblée générale notamment sur kobe
de 19 donc aujourd'hui nous sommes le 10
juillet que nous commençons seulement la
procédure de mise en place de
préparation de la session spéciale sur
et l'infection et toutes les mesures
prises sous forme de travail à distance
sur deux sur l'aspect organisationnel
donc aujourd'hui on en est encore qu à
gauche au niveau organisationnel mais je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse dire que l'onu
régis en retard face à cette infection
simplement que là je vous rappelle que
l'assemblée générale s'est réuni deux
fois sur ce sujet donc deux résolutions
ont été prises pour manifester la
préoccupation de la communauté
internationale face à des menaces et
encore une fois le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu tram à adopter enfin une
résolution chez locaux vides 19
pendant longtemps nous n'avons pas pu le
faire dans la mesure que les américains
je refusait catégoriquement de travail
et d'inclure l'om est-ce dans ce texte
mais nous avons réussi à à souligner le
rôle et nous avons aussi à trouver 1 1
un consensus mais l'om est d'ailleurs
avec la participation des américains
avaient adopté une résolution soutenue
par les américains et qui disait que
l' oms était objectivement soutenu mais
lors de cette session il était déclaré
que dès que la pandémie sera achevée
ainsi que les programmes de lutte contre
l donc nous tirerons les leçons de
l'activité de l'om est sur ce plan mais
pour l'instant aujourd'hui sur le plan
scientifique
il n'y a pas de raison de douter qu'ils
ont travaillé comme des professionnels
et bien entendu notre partenaire proche
nous sommes un pays invité qui
participent régulièrement à la somme des
pays non alignés et tout cela est
important c'est une structure qui dans
un dans un contexte historique très
différent l'époque de la guerre froide
où des pays en voie de développement
cherchait à manifester leur neutralité
face aux deux blocs militaires de
l'époque aujourd'hui les pays
non-alignés joue un rôle dans
l'actualité internationale et cela passe
tout à fait puisque je pense que unis
remettre en place d'aidés des blocs
comme je le dis aujourd'hui cette
volonté artificielle de créer des blocs
casse la neutralité et
au contraire la volonté d'être objectif
est de préserver une certaine
indépendance dans le respect du droit
international est importante
d'ailleurs récemment à bas coût dont je
me 37 et à l'automne dernier il y avait
à bakou une réunion des pays non-alignés
nous étions pays invités donc une
déclaration commune avait été adopté
confirmant encore une fois la position
en faveur de le caractère multi polaire
de la communauté internationale le
soutien à la charte de l'onu et un
soutien à la palestine et à la bolivie à
ce moment là c'était d'une grande
actualité comme thématique et nous
sommes intéressés à ce que notre statut
vis-à-vis des pays non-alignés nous
permettent de travailler sur les
questions qui sont qui présentent un
intérêt pour l'ensemble de ceux des
participants merci internet ce qui
correspondant de pervez khan je vous
propose de prendre la parole sur
l'ukraine via utile d ultimatum de
cosaques sûr
les changements les amendements à la
constitution ukrainienne
étant donné le statut spécial du donbass
cette exigence est devenu assez strictes
matin pourquoi
étant donné que les accords de mr ont
plus de cinquante minutes vous savez que
les exigences les ultimatums n'ont pas
été formulée nous dans le cadre des
conseillers du format normandie et des
dirigeants des quatre pays au niveau du
groupe de contact avec l'ouest me
cherche on a assuré ce dialogue direct
que kiev doit établir avec lougansk et
donetsk et encore une fois nous nous
appuyons sur le principe de base
nous demandons à nos voisins nous
demandons à nos voisins de respecter le
texte des accords de means tel qu'il
était validée par le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu c'est à dire nos collègues les
sucres aignan 10 nous veut rétablir la
frontière intégralement et ensuite
discuté or c'est justement parce qu'ils
étaient conclus ce dans les accorde demi
donc ils font ça intentionnellement donc
on dit que les accords de minsk et s'est
dit par les dirigeants et que les
accords doivent être préservés parce
qu'ils sont la cause du maintien des
sanctions contre la russie je ne peux
pas est ce que ça veut dire que c'est là
l'intérêt principal des accords 2006
est ce que c'est pour cela que l'accord
2000 ce qui a été conclu en local ce qui
a été réellement stipulé dans ces
accords
ils portent de surcroît donc au lieu de
faire des maîtres une mettre en place
une politique de sanction complètement
inadaptée sur la base de sa est donc une
fois ici c'est une approche de principe
et je les dirai les ministères des
affaires étrangères français et allemand
on a parlé avec ses homologues
moi ce que je vois c'est que les
diplomaties française et allemande
s'exprime se sont plaints au lieu
d'entendre des discussions des
déclarations qui détruisent complètement
le processus de minsk
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose avec tout cela nous menons des
discussions pragmatique visant à valider
des étapes concrètes sur la réalisation
des accords demi seconde matière de
sécurité dimension humanitaire social
économique et sur le plan politique et
récemment à berlin lors de la rencontre
des experts du groupe de formats
normandie donc un accord avait été
conclu
qui concernaient par exemple la phase d'
échange de prisonniers et aussi et ça
c'est très important
leur respect des accords conclus par le
groupe de contact sur en matière de
sécurité comprenant la validation des
textes des décrets qui doivent être
adoptées par les parties belligérantes
sur kiev donetsk est lougansk sur les
actions je quitte vont être interdites
et ce texte a été validé et le troisième
point qui a été lui aussi validé
il était à l'ordre du jour de paris
c'est que la mise en place de la vision
kiev sur la modification de la
constitution ukrainienne pour le statut
particulier de donetsk est lougansk
conformément à la résolution kate qui a
validé les accords de minsk or tout cela
doit être formalisée dans le cadre du
groupe de contact qui s'est achevée il
ya quelques ans la délégation
ukrainienne a désapprouvé tous ceux tous
ceux qui avaient été conclus et qui
correspondait aux déclarations faites
précédemment
donc ici il n'ya pas ici de surprise
nous avons toujours dit que nous étions
pour le respect strict et complet des
accords de minsk et aujourd'hui nous
avons nous avons pas un manque de
patience comme on dit mais mais la
patience l aide quand y'a une clarté des
sables mais aujourd'hui j'en à monsieur
zelensky aujourd'hui président qui s'est
fait élire sur sa volonté de mettre en
place la paix et mais aujourd'hui on
veut le respect des accords de je pose
la question
eq si beau jeune co directeur de la
politique extérieure telle interfax il y
a vingt trois sets dans ses mémoires
bolton écrit que trump et dès qu'on est
content à des sanctions sur soc berry
avez vous reçu des signaux de ce genre à
un style l'accord sur l'abolition des
visites au plus haut niveau entre les
etats-unis et la russie et troisième
question est-ce qu'il ya la possibilité
de participer à g7
[Musique]
bon j'ai pas lu ses mémoires moi-même de
john bolton mais les descriptions de
certaines thématiques abordées dans sa
mémoire on comprend que bolton propre
avis sur les relations russo-américaines
et sur la mission de l'amérique dans le
monde et sur la façon dont l'amérique
doit traiter l'ordre mondial
mais bref
tous à peu près tout livre tout
américain qui a travaillé un ou deux ans
dans la diplomatie américaine écrit un
livre et se fait publier et a beaucoup
de lecteurs
donc il ya un certain nombre de thèmes
qui permettent de bien se vendre
donc je lui laisse la responsabilité des
propos qu'il tient et qui le
découvraient pour attiser l'intérêt de
ses lecteurs et je dirais que c'est sa
responsabilité de rendre ces caractères
piquant et en déformant la réalité d'une
façon ou d'une autre la question c'était
pardon sur l'abolition des visions de
visite n'y a pas d'accord en ce sens qui
a été
conclut passé un accord sur une visite
ça veut dire une date concrète dans une
ville un lieu géographique précis mais
aujourd'hui
personne ne refuse de faire des visites
mais nous avons le souhait de travailler
avec les américains tous les niveaux et
les présidents de bons contacts et je
m'entretiens régulièrement avec mike
chong bo et puis au niveau 2 de messages
anti il ya aussi de bons contacts donc
là encore une fois nous ne vois pas
l'intérêt des américains à une
détérioration de nos relations
je vois pas l'intérêt de en fonction des
l'antre du show internes des états unis
avant les élections mais en ce qui
concerne le g7 nous avons dit tout ce
qui devait être dit à ce sujet il y
avait le g ville auquel participaient de
plein droit la russie mais dont elle a
été exclue pas par sa faute
les les américains et les japonais décès
de ne pas y participer c'est leur choix
et le président l'a dit nous ne serons
toujours prêts à accueillir le g8 en
russie si nos collègues ne veulent pas
venir on va pas on va pas les forcer et
ça c'est que en ce qui concerne le g7
la liste des pays qu'a rappelé le
président américain
en tant que l'invité potentiel manifeste
le fait que le jeu s'est en fait ne peut
rien résoudre mais parmi les pays qui
ont été
c'était sais pas si la situation va
changer
vad également puisque je suis pas
certain que tous les pays qui figurent
dans cette triste pense l'on puisse
avoir une discussion sur la politique
économique et financière dans le monde
puisse se faire sans les chinois de
façon efficace et donc il est évident
que tout cela est que toutes ces raisons
font que réunir l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques juridiques politiques et un
sur l'ensemble du monde donc puissent se
réunir potable donc ces raisons montre
qu'il faut encore une fois travail au
plus haut niveau au sein du g20 c'est un
mécanisme inclusif qui fonctionne sur la
base du consensus de l'égalité de droit
et si on parle du fond des proches des
programmes qui se pose aujourd'hui et
non pas de l'utilisation qui en est
faite dans les polémiques et bien
entendu le g20 c'est manifeste c'est
évident j'essaie d'un format qui a
besoin d'être préservée encourager et
activement utilisés la question finale
correspondant spécial commerçante et la
nature nous quoi en russie en tue
toujours qu'on est près de travailler
avec tout le président élu par le peuple
américain pour vivo évaluer le
développement possible des relations
russo américaines
si gagner maiden à votre avis
l'idée était justifiée que j'ose pas
eden pourrait revoir revenir sur cette
décision qui ne sont pas
profitable pour la russie nous n'avons
pas l'habitude de commenter les
campagnes électorales
les médias s'en occuper dans tous les
pays c'est la même chose et la campagne
électorale américaine suscite un intérêt
soutenu dans la presse partout dans le
monde
mais tout cela et nous agissons nous
considérons que c'est le choix du peuple
américain c'est tout vous comprenez si
on parle de la façon dont cela peut se
manifester pour les relations russo
américaines
quelle que soit l'issue de ces élections
il ya des commentaires d'experts qui
disent que passer à des discussions sur
le désarmement
je pense qu'effectivement il ya des
faits qui montrent que les démocrates
sont moins orientées que les
républicains vers une destruction
désaccord sur les armes qui ont été
mises en place au show des dernières
décennies mais nous nous souvenons
encore une fois que à l'époque
obama donc ma crainte c'est là qui a été
déclenché la plus grande offensive anti
américaine avec notamment l'utilisation
des sanctions et qui fait aujourd'hui
l'objet du consensus entre les deux
parties donc je vais pas chercher à
deviner ce qui va se passer
la situation est
peu prévisible et c'est le choix des
américains
le bureau sur le démo que la démocratie
et les droits de l'homme de l'eau et
ceux qui assurent notamment la
surveillance des élections et qui a
assuré pour la première fois une
surveillance à distance ici a publié un
rapport cette semaine elle a manifesté
un certain nombre de réclamations de
plainte
le système électoral tel qu'il
organisait aujourd'hui conformément à la
légère mais rien de gens n'entrent pas
dans les détails
ce rapport est accessible au public
on sait que plus de deux millions de
citoyens mais qui sont privées du droit
de vote qui qui il aurait qui leur
échoit par la législation
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que il
ya un effet aussi ici qui se manifeste
dans le fait que c'est le caractère à
deux étages du processus électoral c'est
dire que d'abord on est lui de grands
électeurs
on élit deux grands électeurs et qui
eux-mêmes ensuite elle est là remarque
était qu' il n'y a pas une égalité de
droit au niveau des groupes ethniques et
c'est une remarque intéressante de la
part de l'ess nous en avons parlé il ya
déjà longtemps ce canton d'eauze
condolezza rice était secrétaire d'état
américain nous en avions parlé elle
avait manifesté certaines plantes sur
les élections qui s'étaient déroulés ici
peut-être en 2008 je me souviens plus
très bien mais je l'avais dit en réponse
que
s'il ya des réclamations concrètes nous
avons des observateurs internationaux
qui viennent il ya des organismes de
contrôle qui viennent et se le rappeler
que aux états unis justement on peut
obtenir des voix en fonction de la
répartition territoriale la répartition
des voix
peut-être ça m'a rappelé l'année 2008 où
il y avait un recompte des voix en
floride pendant très longtemps est
finalement ce recours avait fait que
george bush avait été élu et al gore
avait reconnu que donc nous arrachons
m'avait dit oui je sais que c'est un
problème mais c'est notre problème à
nous et on va le traiter et je pense que
c'est comme ça qu'ils vont réagir au
rapport de l'eau et ce en ce qui
concerne les projections qu'on peut
faire à partir de tel ou tel résultat
sur les accords et notamment l'accord
ciel ouvert
encore une fois les etats-unis
conformément alors décision de se
retirer de cet accord
ils doivent se retirer le 22 novembre
c'est à dire deux semaines et demie
après les élections
donc quel que soit le président la
nouvelle administration n'entre en
fonction que le 20 janvier ce qui
signifie que est ce que cette décision
va être revu dans cette situation je
sais pas mais
s'il ya une nouvelle administration
démocrate
est-ce qu'elle reviendra sur la
discussion sur ce sur cet accord à
partir de zéro je ne sais pas donc sur
la conférence exceptionnelle du 6
juillet dernier sur le système le régime
de ces loups verts nous nous sommes mis
d'accord sur le fait que nous avons nous
sommes prêts à maintenir cet accord et
qu'il continue de fonctionner mais la
décision finale dépendra de toutes les
conséquences de la décision que prendra
les états unis sur une décision qui
finalement définitive c'est à dire
puisque apparemment ils vont pas changer
d'avis et ils vont effectivement se
retirer de cet accord
ces nouvelles sur les armes a porté un
termine intermédiaire encore une fois
dans toutes nos tentatives de les
persuader de revenir à l'accord sont
restées sans succès encore une fois nous
sommes prêts à avoir une situation où la
volonté politique qui est des états unis
et de détruire l'ensemble de ses
systèmes d'accord et nous sommes prêts
au fait que n'ont pas commencé à partir
de zéro d'une feuille blanche mais à
reprendre contact avec nos homologues
américains pour travailler de pour
discuter de l'ensemble de ces questions
je pense que c'est la position qui est
adoptée par l'ensemble des représentants
de la communauté internationale et nous
laissons la porte ouverte à une
discussion et est encore une fois ces
discussions doivent se faire sur la base
du volontariat c'est à dire la volonté
de travailler et et que les positions
soient équilibrés les se désespère vous
connaissent comme quelqu'un qui est
prête une attention particulière la
liste des experts et ses deux heures en
confirmant que vous avez cette étude
particulière cercles scientifiques
si beaucoup et j'espère que nous allons
va retrouver en personne déjà pendant la
conférence
merci à vous chers collègues et bon
week-end à vous tous